all right Rebecca is with us in Fargo
North Dakota hi Rebecca how are you
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up years ago before my
husband and I started your plan he had a
emergency open heart surgery yet
undiagnosed condition and came out of
his overnight surgery with an artificial
heart valve and a synthetic aorta Wow
how old is now he was 36 at the time mmm
okay and how long ago was this two years
okay how's he doing great good okay but
he can't get life insurance
oh he headed through this company and he
has changed jobs and now the most we can
get ahold of is like a $40,000 plan
through through work we we worked with a
few brokers and did you try and earn the
birth plan tried Zander they couldn't
help us okay yeah I suspect I think
that's probably accurate yeah because
this is a pretty extreme surgery on a
very young guy and so I suspect over
time though he will become more
insurable is that what you've been told
and we did finally find a broker who was
able to get us in touch with Prudential
and they could do $500,000 policy on a
20-year term for two hundred and fifteen
dollars and we're just wondering is that
you know but it seems like such a high
amount for turns that's ridiculous you
know it's up to you guys I mean you have
children we have a two-year-old he was
three months old when all this went down
and then we
one on the way in January okay and what
does your husband make he makes about
47,000 mm-hmm and what do you make right
around that same mark okay right here's
the thing what you're balancing this off
against is that's a very very expensive
policy and then the risk is if God
forbid something happens to him you got
to raise these kids so I would pick the
40,000 up for sure and I think you can
pick up some other odds and ends
policies that are no met non-medical
meaning they don't we actually got an
email from a letter from a previous
employer things that he could continue
the policy that they had with them if we
just start paying that company directly
it would just be another 40,000 but it's
like $8 a month do it do it definitely
do that that's a lot better deal than
the other one right and so in the other
place you may be able to pick it up
that's cheaper than we're talking about
what proof is the owner home we call
your mortgage company and see if they
sell any mortgage life mortgage life is
about 5x normal but proves quoting you
more than 5x normal okay and then you
can just look at it so we're talking
about $2,400 a year out of your income
of ninety thousand and you can have a
half a million dollars and insurance
it's up to you how worried you are about
that but I'm with you it's up to you
know how how are you gonna feel if god
forbid something happens to him and and
well you gotta raise these kids that's
that's what we're worried about here
right right well we we got on your plan
a year and a half ago and over the next
nine months we did get that free 21300
and nine months and we listened to your
radio so much that our son calls you
Uncle Dave I mean if you did do the
prove policy I would say let's do it and
let's just plan on keeping it a couple
years
and during that time you know finish off
being out of dad have your emergency
fund start really building wealth and
maybe he starts to become insurable with
some distance between the event and you
know the longer it's been since he had
the surgery the more insurer more likely
he is to be insurable at a reasonable
rate so I might go ahead and take it as
a temporary thing it's not your
permanent answer but I might take it as
a temporary thing just say you know
we're gonna do this we're gonna do it
for two years and then we're gonna look
at it again that's that's a with a baby
and a two year old yeah probably what
you're making 90 household I probably
would spend two thousand four hundred
bucks I probably would and I pick up the
other two two just for the fun of it
just have them in place because they're
not that expensive and you have another
80 grand right there and then then let's
just decide two years from now try again
see if we can get a policy and look at
your situation we're debt-free we've got
this pile of money oh I feel a whole lot
better now you know and that changes the
equation thanks for calling in see folks
that's what happens you want to not only
have you want to have insurance that's
not only at your company because of what
you just experienced you lose the
insurance when you leave the company in
this case they're letting even go back
and get it for some reason but that's
unusual but you know you have an event
and then you leave the company you lose
the insurance you get a cancer diagnosis
or a heart diagnosis or something like
that and the second thing that we get
out of that call that you need to learn
is this idea of that as you decrease
your debt as your children get older and
as you increase your wealth your need
for insurance is going down as you
decrease your debt increase your wealth
and your children get older in other
words if you've got an 18 year old you
have $500,000 in mutual funds and you
have no debt your need for insurance is
a lot less than if you have debt and a
two-year-old
that you got a raise for the next 18
years right or 16 years or whatever you
want to measure that but the point being
the older the children get and and/or
leave home as they grow up and you'd
have zero debt and you build wealth you
do away with your need for life
insurance over time and that's just from
good financial planning is all that is
so good question
thank you for joining us I'm sorry
you're facing all that I'm glad he's
doing so good that's great it's pretty
amazing if you think about it so that
that's why we don't buy whole life life
insurance which is roughly 20 times more
expensive because you take the other 19
times and you do your investing there
and you get out of debt there so when
you invent as you invest overtime and
you say for 20 years I'm going to invest
15% of my household income because I
paid off all my household debt not
counting my mortgage and during that 20
years I get my house paid off and during
that 20 years the kids grow up and leave
and so now you're not 30 with a
two-year-old now you're 50 with a 22
year old and you're debt-free and you've
got five six seven hundred thousand
dollars in mutual funds
now if your husband dies in that
situation your wife dies in that
situation you know you're debt-free no
kids at home and you got seven hundred
thousand if you had no insurance you'd
be just fine and so you buy by
increasing your wealth increasing your
net worth decreasing your debt
increasing your your investments and by
raising the kids and they are grown and
gone or closer to growing gone your need
for insurance dissipates every year so
in her situation as they hang on for two
more years you know the kids are two
years older they're two years further
down the pike saving and investing and
they've finished up getting rid of the
debt except for the home and the house
is even starting to go away see their
need for insurance two years from now is
less than it would be today and we buy
20 year level term and take you all the
way out to give you a comfort level
it changes everything if you start to
look at the insurance through the lens
of actually financial planning instead
of the lens of what your insurance agent
wants you to do which is give them a
commission
this is the Dave Ramsey show